البدايه من صحيفه نيويورك تايمز التي
تحدثت عن ازمه الغذاء في غزه وقالت ان
المجاعه اصبحت مصدر قلق انساني رئيسي في
القطاع حيث ان جميع الاسر تقريبا لا
يمكنها الحصول على وجبات الطعام بانتظام
وفقا للامم المتحده وعلى اساس نصيب الفرد
من الغذاء قال بوب كيتشن من لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه ان ازمه الجوع في غزه هي اكثر
ازمه حده شاهدتها في حياتي حتى ال
تطرقت افتتاحيه صحيفه لوموند الى اتهام
اسرائيل موظفي الاونور بالمشاركه في هجمات
حماس في السابع من اكتوبر ورات ان هذه
الافعال يجب الا تستخدم ضد وكاله يعد
عملها ضروريا لتجنب وقوع كارثه انسانيه
وتابعت الافتتاحيه ان العلاقات السيئه
بالفعل بين اسرائيل والامم المتحده
ستتدهور اكثر نتيجه لهذه الاتهامات واشارت
الى انه منذ بدايه للازمه الحاليه تزايدت
علامات عدم الثقه لدى اسرائيل تجاه
الوكالات التي تدين بلا كلل الكارثه
الانسانيه المستمره في
غزه قالت صحيفه يديعوت احرونوت ان وزير
الامن القومي اتمار بن كفير حذر في رساله
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو من انه
سيعطل عمل الائتلاف من جانبه ومن جانب
حزبه على خلفيه تقارير ميدانيه تفيد بان
الجنود المكلفين بح راسه الشريط الامني
الناشئ في شمال قطع غزه لم يسمح لهم
باطلاق النار على الفلسطينيين الذين
يقتربون منه بن كفير طالب بتطبيق تعليمات
اطلاق النار ويعتقد ان هناك مئات الحالات
التي وصل فيها سكان غزه الى مسافه قصيره
من الحدود مع اسرائيل لكن صدرت تعليمات
للقوات الاسرائيليه بعدم اطلاق النار
عليهم قال موقع اكسيوس الاخباري ان الر
رئيس جو بايدن وكبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
ناقشوا ردا عسكريا كبيرا ضد الميليشيات
المواليه لايران على اثر الهجوم الذي اردى
جنو امريكيين في الاردن واضاف الموقع ان
اجتماعات عده رفيعه المستوى عقدت يوم
الاحد للنظر في طبيعه الرد اضافه الى
الاجتماع الذي شارك فيه بايدن وقال اكسيوس
ان مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه بيل
برنز انضم الى بعض المشاورات بشان الرد
الامر
من جهته راى مقال في صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال ان اداره بايدن يتعين عليها ان
تدرس ردا قويا بما يكفي لردع حلفاء ايران
عن شن مزيد من الهجمات على القوات
والمصالح الامريكيه مع تجنب التورط في حرب
اخرى في الشرق الاوسط واشارت الصحيفه الى
تزايد التوترات في المنطقه منذ شنت
اسرائيل حربها على غزه لكن مقتل ثلاثه من
افراد الخدمه الامريكيه
يزيد بشكل كبير المخاطر بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده والضغوط على اداره بايدن
خصوصا في عام
الانتخابات